well yesterday Senator Ted Cruz he
confronted Biden's Homeland Security
secretary mayorkas on this very issue
let's take a look has the crisis at our
Southern border
made Americans less safe yes or no
Senator we are dedicated to the safety
has the crisis made Americans less safe
I don't I don't want a discourse it's a
yes or no question
Senator we have a challenge you refuse
to answer the question how many children
have been sexually assaulted by human
traffickers under the Biden
Administration
Senator this is precisely why we
Institute I don't want a lecture it's a
question how many children have been
sexually assaulted by human traffickers
under your Administration Senator this
is this is exactly why on January 5th
again do you know how many do you know
how many children have been sexually
assaulted this is why we say you're
going to refuse to answer that question
as well Mr secretary I want to say to
you right now it is your behavior is
disgraceful and the deaths the children
assaulted the children raped they are at
your feet and if you had Integrity you
would reside
and I will tell you the men and women of
the border patrol they've never had a
political leader undermine them they
despise you Mr secretary because you're
willing to let children be raped
to follow political orders wow powerful
joining us now Texas Senator Ted Cruz is
with a senator
[Music]
thank you Senator
um
so I've been down on the border myself
all the way from the Rio Grande to San
Diego probably 15 times horseback
helicopters boats on foot on Horseback
I've done it all we know Sarah Carter
has been down there they know everything
that you said to mayorkas is proven to
be true the cartels run this and the
issue about young children being raped
we did an entire report about it with
one witness after another and even
physical evidence that Sarah Carter was
able to obtain the drugs the fentanyl
all of it's happening and you know what
not only is mallorca's incompetent
they're aiding abetting and helping the
effort by allowing it to happen they
don't have to allow that
Sean that is exactly right they are
allowing it because they've made a
political choice at the beginning of the
Biden Administration they decided
unlimited illegal immigration open
borders they view every one of the 5.5
million illegal immigrants who's come in
under Joe Biden as a future Democrat
voter and so they're perfectly willing
to turn a blind eye they don't care
about the children who are physically
assaulted who are sexually assaulted
they don't care about the women who are
raped they don't care about the dead
bodies that are piling up you know when
I took a group of senators down there we
saw a dead body of an immigrant floating
who had drowned in the Rio Grande I've
sat there with Texas farmers who show me
photographs of pregnant women and
elderly people and pre and toddlers left
to die in the Texas desert they don't
care it's a deliberate choice and I
gotta say mayorkas number one that
entire hearing he refused to answer a
single question you couldn't ask him
what day it was or what time of day it
was he he had this arrogance of how dare
you question me and I got to say of the
whole thing the most astonishing moment
is in that last clip you played next to
me was a poster board with pictures of a
whole series of wristbands and I asked
him I said Mr secretary what are these
wristbands what a moment this was
explain what those wristbands are
so he answered and said I don't know
what they are and I gotta admit that
astonished me I couldn't have imagined
that was the case those are the
wristbands as you know Sean that just
about every illegal immigrant wears on
their wrists and the cartels give it to
them they are color-coded for how many
thousands of dollars that those
individuals owe the cartels and for
thousands upon thousands of those little
boys they get sent to cities all across
America by majorcus and by Biden and
they work for the cartels they're
criminals in cities All Over America and
for a great many of the teenage girls
they get sent into sex slavery these
bracelets
their modern day leg irons and and to
see the head of of Homeland Security say
he doesn't even know what they are this
guy doesn't give a damn it's it's why at
the end I said if you had a shred of
Integrity you would resign right now but
he doesn't he's willing to put politics
over the lives that are being lost
including the over a hundred thousand
Americans killed last year from
overdoses he's not willing to do a thing
to stop it and even worse he's going to
continue the policies that are causing
these tragedies and I would bet knowing
that we have already caught many people
on the terror watch list that people on
that list have have made it across
meaning we have terror cells right here
in America what frustrates me Senator
the most when I talk about this issue is
the fact that they keep lying we're
going to have by the end of this year
well over 6 million illegal immigrants
in this country because Joe Biden is
allowing them into the country but they
keep telling us that the border is
secure the border is not secure you you
got in and got pictures of children in
cages we try to send our cameras down
there they were turned around every
single time you shared the evidence in
the video with this show and you know
what they denied it was happening until
we had the evidence so how do they say
with a straight face that the border is
secure
look their strategy is just hide if you
watch Fox News if you watch a handful of
right-of-center outlets you can find out
the truth about what's happening but but
if you watch CNN if you watch MSNBC or
ABC CBS NBC there is no border crisis
they don't cover it and and it says
something that the Democrats they don't
even try to defend this because you
can't look at the facts it used to be
Democrats would Preen around and say
they're Humane they're compassionate
they just care more you know they don't
do that anymore because if you actually
look at what's happening you cannot
defend This Disaster and so their entire
plan is built on the complicity of the
corporate media I got to say after this
hearing after mayorkas couldn't answer
anything most of the corporate media
completely ignored the hearing they just
pretended it didn't happen now I will
give you a a moment a glimmer of hope
perhaps it's something I talked about
today in my podcast verdict with Ted
Cruz in the middle of the hearing when
mayorcus is getting lit up
he turned to the chairman of the
Judiciary Committee Dick Durbin the very
partisan Democrat from Illinois and he
said Mr chairman will you help me and
I've spent 11 years on Judiciary with
Durbin he's very smart he's very
partisan he loves to fight with me he
and I have gone 15 rounds more times
than I can count
it's the only time in 11 years I've seen
Durbin decline an invitation he just sat
back and kind of shrugged and I gotta
say I took that Sean as Senate Democrats
realizing uh oh we're in a bad spot on
this This Disaster at the southern
border and we're leaving and basically
he was saying to majorcus you're on your
own and I think they are getting ready
to throw him overboard fire him and then
try to blame everything on him now they
don't intend to change anything well but
they want him to be the one who takes
the blame in order to insulate Biden and
Kamala Harris and all the Senate
Democrats that giggling vice president
borders are has not been too effective
and they haven't been down there and
they don't know what you know and I know
and Sarah Carter knows and the people in
Texas and and Arizona and other states
know Senator a very powerful day thank
you we appreciate you being with us hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else